fend bien l'école c'est
bien allô
chéri la RAM
bulletinexcellent cade pour allez à tout
à l'heure
apparemment mon prendre bien l'é colle
oui
papa tombe
bien un petit cadeau pour mon café
merci mon
téléphone
tu
là elle est là allez dormi
oui longtemps dedans quo vous fait fait
mal
papa euh tu en penses quoi pa
quoi mon ch mon
là l'bl de sac ah
oui mercient bonne
journée
Jupiter donc jupiter est la peine des
planètes i là tu n'écoutes plus en cours
tes notes sont en chute libre ton
comportement est vraiment inadmissible
va voir le principal tout de
suite
mademoiselle on vous a dit que c'était
interdit d'utiliser les téléphone
portable en
classe et en plus on n pas à taper son
professeur évidemment j'ai obligé de de
la Monsieur
Madame voilà donc la mesure d'exculion
va prendre lieu voilà on va vous
demander de
signer
sie
werlprer körperlicher no psicht nein
dankehatig
alle
allezi
y